evening and congratulations buddy
thank you we live in a time when now
more than ever all of us need to
understand the importance of what is
real what is authentic and what is fact
that is why documentary filmmakers our
revolutionaries play such a vital role
for their stories of truth of actual
people and actual events can cut through
the clutter and noise and help us shape
our understanding of the real world we
live in here are the nominees for Best
Documentary Feature abacus small enough
to jail Steve James mark mitten and
Julie Goldman faces places onions
Florida jr. and Rosa Lee pardon fool
Icarus Brian Fogle and Dan Cogan
last men in Aleppo furious fired her
and sorenstein yes person strong island
Yancey forth and joseline bonds
and the Oscar goes to Icarus
[Applause]
is the first Oscar
nomination
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you to the Academy
thanks to Ted Saran dose Lisa Nishimura
and Adam Dell do our incredible partners
at Netflix UTA Rina Ronson but our
fellow producers Jim Swartz and David
fee Alko and our amazing creative team
John Burton Mark Munroe Jake's Marko
Adam Peters and my parents who are here
I love you guys we dedicate this award
we dedicate this award to dr. Gregory
Burke chenkov our fearless whistleblower
who now lives in grave danger
we hope Icarus is a wake-up call yes
about Russia but more than that about
the importance of telling the truth now
more than ever - my wife Liz Garvey's
you taught me everything I know about
how to support a great filmmaker because
you are one Amelia and Theo I love you
and jerilyn Dreyfuss and all the members
of impact partners thank you all for
making films like Icarus possible thank
you
[Applause]